you are Mondrian's worst art critic a
hundred years ago you tell him he can no
longer create art where two rectangles
have the same dimension that's just
wrong you're going to say okay I'm going
to score each of your pieces of art
we're going to insist that all of the
rectangles have got different dimensions
and your score is going to be equal to
your largest area of rectangle - your
smallest area of rectangle your smallest
score possible is what you want to go
for the other condition is that you have
to tile the whole canvas so let's let's
start out Brady how big do you want this
first rectangle to be 3 by 2 3 by 2 okay
there's a 3 by 2 so we can no longer
make a 2 by 3 or a 3 by 2 anywhere else
then I can make a 6 by 1 you can't make
a 6 by 1
in fact why do we do that there we go
there is a 6 by 1 what else would you
like in here should we make that little
square that 2x2 2x2 yeah and if you were
to stop right now this is area 20 so if
you were to stop right now your score
would be 20 that's your biggest - your
smallest for your score would be 16 and
that is not very good you want low and
16 is not low enough so what we could we
do we could split this into an 8 here
and a 12 we could do that and so now our
score is 12 minus 4 is equal to 8 you
can tell Mondrian you are scoring this
an 8 you can score 5 so let me let me
show you this one your largest rectangle
is 8 - your smallest is 3 so that scores
5 and that is the best possible score
that you can get for a 6x6 Mondrian art
puzzle of course you have to ask
yourself what about a 7 by 7
what about an 8 by 8 what about an
n-by-n what is the optimal add peg has
happened to prove solutions he's proven
that we have these optimal solutions
beautiful results and great for algebra
classes
well to come up with general solutions
so for example for an odd square let's
say that you are dealing with a square
101 by a hundred and one well at least
you know for sure that you can split
this nearly in two so that this is a
rectangle 50 times 101 and this
rectangle is 51 times 101 and you can
see right away that your score for any
odd square you can see that it's just
the edge length so you can guaranteed
that you can at least do a hundred and
one you can actually do a lot better
than 101 but you can at least do 101 an
unsolved problem here is Willis number
ever go to zero you would think well
this has got to increase but it doesn't
always increase for example is 17 by 17
the score for that is only 8 on the
score for 16 by 16 15 by 15 I think
they're larger so this does not continue
to increase it's a very complicated
function and it is not clear that this
for example doesn't go to 0 presumably
God the Holy Grail is some kind of
generalization for an N by n square the
solution will always be you know n cubed
minus 4 plus 4 oh that would be a joy
again but good luck good luck dream on
you can follow it all the way through